قبل عامين تلقينا من وضع الأسلحة الساخنة شيئا من هذا القبيل
التبرع هو التبرع، وكان الوضع مستحيلا
سيستمر الأمر على هذا النحو، لا يمكننا أن نكون أصدقاء للمحاربين
تتوقع منا أن نحارب الحد الأدنى من الطاعة
أوريم تقبل سيدنا منهم أصدقاؤنا قد رحلوا
همسنا وفقط في موجة من اليأس دخلنا دون كلمة واحدة
لا يوجد كريم ولا التزام وقائي بالوقت الذي أقضيه في شركتي
الوضع أفضل قليلا مرة أخرى للجميع
يفعلون
يمكن أن تصل Betza إلى بضعة أمتار من الكابل الموجود في K of Makko
أنه يبدو أنه يحدد في هذا من tsi حاييم كما يقول
امتلاك كل شيء يعني عدم قول أي شيء، نحن نرفع
هو - هي
الحدود القصوى
أنظر، من الواضح أن هناك عيوب وهناك عيوب
وهذه هي أطول حرب تخوضها دولة إسرائيل منذ ذلك الحين
الحرب السوداء أكثر من 300 إله حسب ماذا
الذين يعلنون عن تعبئة ومسح المحاور اللوجستية
لتوريد معدات الذخيرة الغذائية أثناء الحرب
يهودا والسامرة قطاع غزة الحدود الشمالية حادة
مشروع لوجستي لم يشارك فيه الجيش الإسرائيلي مطلقًا
نظرت إلى ما كان هذا الجندي يسحبه من المقبض
الاعتداء كنت منتظمًا منذ سنوات عديدة
لقد حاولنا أيضًا الحصول عليه لأنه موجود أيضًا في قسم المهام
دعنا نسميها ذلك أو سأقولها بطريقة أخرى
طالما أنه يعطى أن دولة إسرائيل راضية فقط
تحقيقاً لهدف إعادة المختطفين إلى ديارهم
وإسرائيل تواصل هذه الحملة وتستمر
ودفع ثمن استراتيجي باهظ لذلك في السنوات القادمة
ليس لدى إسرائيل خيار آخر سوى هزيمة
حماس وعودة المختطفين جزء من الأمر الكبير
إن النصر الكبير في الحرب ليس هناك ما يمكن الحديث عنه
وهذا معنى بديل للاستسلام في الوقت الحالي للأمر
والأولوية التي تسجل فقط عودة المختطفين هي هذه
خسارة استراتيجية في هذه الحملة وفي هذا القتال
وهذا يعني أن ما يستسلم لحماس هو من هي حماس على أية حال
أولا أطلقوا سراح المختطفين إن شاء الله تعالى
يقوم رامي إيجر الآن باختراع نظرية قتالية جديدة فقط
بالقوة هنا رأيت ما حدث للتو
بالقوة قمت بإحضار جميع المختطفين لدينا إلى الداخل
التوابيت المقدسة أولا نقول إننا
لا يُعرف سوى القليل جدًا عن حفر الذراع
وعسكر حمص بشكل خاص على الشخص الذي يعيش في المزارع
سنوات عديدة وهو يعرف أيضًا ما يعنيه
أنه بعد واحدة من محاولات القضاء على الحديث حقا
في إسرائيل لكون جانبه الأيسر بأكمله
مشلول يفقد عينك
هذا المفهوم لديه عين، وليس عين، نعم
الأطراف ليست أطرافًا، الشكل أ أقل
ذات الصلة وأيضا نوع من كسر المفهوم
لماذا هو أقل أهمية لأنه في نهاية الصفحة كان هناك
تورط عميق جداً في الذراع العسكري لحماس
وهذا هو، حتى لو كان محدودا جسديا
لا أقول أن اللغة كانت محدودة، كان جدا
منخرط جدًا في مستوى التركيز الذي أخبرني به ذات مرة
شخص يصل إلى مستوى الأجنحة في الصاروخ هو هو
انخفض إلى دقة منخفضة جدًا جدًا جدًا
صغير في لون لحم الخنزير وما زال ينزل
وهو أمر مهم في محمد ع وكان معروفا على طول أنه ليس كذلك
كم عدد أصابعه وكم عدد عيونه؟
يا له من عقل هذا الرجل لديه القدرة
معرفياً وأصبح نور بقائه في الأمة
عدة محاولات اغتيال تعرضت لها الرمز والجمعية الحضرية
اسمه ذاته يلهم التحفيز بين المقاتلين
نحن على مر السنين في العديد والعديد من الحالات
وقمنا بتصفية قادة حماس في إحدى قرى المدينة
وفي منطقة محمد رغم أهميتها الكبيرة
ومركزيته في حركة حماس ليست سوى أداة في الداخل
هذه المنظمة وحتى بعد أن خصصناها أنا بالفعل
يصنع المفسد حتى بعد أن أقضي عليه سيكون هناك
الأشخاص الذين سيأخذون مكانه ويستمرون في القيام بذلك
ما يفعلونه وبالتالي أعتقد أنني أتعلق بالسبب
ويقول شنيري إن إقصائه مهم أيضًا على المستوى
المبدأ الذي نتبعه هؤلاء الناس هو هذا
ليس ما سيكون الآن نقطة تحول في هذه الحرب
أول شيء، ثاني شيء، هذه القصة أيضًا
لقد عرفنا على الأقل علنًا شيئًا عن محمد
الأنف أو على الأقل ما يبثونه لنا عن محمد
حتى مرآة إلى حد ما